yeah sweet how harsh Angeles Crocodile
Dundee
oh man all right thank you
we share
Rober by the way that's right it
mentions Iago
Oh
yeah
ah
it's a different
so there's a blue light right here and
these are blue blockers so what happens
Science Guy stoppage in journal patio
furniture dream I don't like at all oh
really large with luck I can't doubt
hold on watch still rolling see if I get
this on the first try right here okay
ready
all right get me up close kinda okay
where my liner footer arm I got my foot
okay here we go
yeah that really happened I just put
this decal on my computer and then I
read the instructions which says take a
credit card the only time I was keep in
mind that me and this guy save this guy
and I yeah you already didn't [ __ ] like
this put it like smash good I haven't
done this with you for a long yeah there
actually is bubbles in here this is
great oh my god I do this one I am going
to set that laptop so if you ever see
this computer in the airport please
return to Stevo open oh my god this
actually works like the Christian has so
a model in computers so I might as well
go ahead and admit even though it might
break some hearts that I've been getting
my [ __ ] [ __ ] tattoos lasered off why
well I don't know I was pretty sure
getting [ __ ] [ __ ] tattooed on my
knuckles would make me a legend
I thought Ozzy would bow to me and my
intensity but over ten years later it
seemed nobody gave a [ __ ] I'm super
proud that I that I skated through life
with no consequences whatsoever having
[ __ ] [ __ ] on my knuckles I think that's
beautiful but at the same time you know
it's really kind of outlived its
usefulness oh my god you're doing an
incredible job there by the well thanks
dude boom
I bet 46
ah Macbook stickers with what when
vlogging goes bad yeah you gotta be
careful bunch on your screen I know dude
what time I integrate onto my email
address the whole world I think one guys
sent me a rat email to it like I send my
care package please do not please do not
give this to anyone here's a couple of
hits of rat [ __ ] I love you brother